[Music]
now the thing i remember saying at the
beginning of this whole foldables wave
is if we really want these foldables to
catch on if this really is the future of
how smartphones could be
then the tech is going to have to get
better and better to the point where
folding in half
is just another feature right there
can't be huge compromises or massive
price tags or awkward things about it it
has to just be one more thing because at
that point you know it's kind of cool
that it folds but that's when early
adopters are going to give it a shot and
really see what it's about but if you
want everyone to be trying these things
it's got to be just one more feature
it's got to be a normal phone in every
other way
except for the fact that it also folds
in half that's when it gets interesting
so with this phone the z flip 3 the
ambition is still pretty simple give us
a regular phone for regular use and then
let us fold it shut into a sort of
smaller form factor kind of like a
throwback to the flip phones of
yesteryear now there's a couple new
features on this year's version that
really make it that much more usable it
doesn't change a ton but there are a few
key things that make a big difference so
in my order of importance it would be
the new refresh design which is pretty
sweet the much improved build quality
and the bigger much more usable outside
cover screen so the new design is pretty
sweet it reminds me of the classic panda
pixel 2 which is one of my favorite
phone designs ever but it also looks and
feels more refined too they squared up
those sides you know they've shifted
obviously you can see to a two-tone look
and there's some new colors this cream
color has gotten a lot of love but
there's also a pretty sweet green and
yes it does come in matte black if
you're under that or you can just grab
an icon skin from the link in the
description and make it look even more
sick i'm just saying link below now
there's a funny little quirk of using a
phone that's this shape which is when
you fold it
it's basically a square and so you put
it in your pocket and a lot of times you
flip it by accident or maybe it's upside
down or whatever it can be in your
pocket in any number of different
orientations and so when you pull it out
of your pocket there's this brief moment
where you have to
figure out where you're at figure out
what's right side up and so this dual
tone front and also the little tiny
indentation for the fingerprint reader
power button on the side has been my way
of just like quickly finding home and
getting into using the phone and so i
kind of it's got a little utility i like
that and i really like that they found a
lot of other subtle little things to
improve about the build quality too the
flat sides like i said really nice but
also this hinge is even more sturdy and
will hold almost any angle you want
until it's nearly shut which is when the
magnets take over and give this
satisfying
that clap when it slaps shut
it's a nice hinge and it also now
happens to be ipx8 water resistant so
while you should absolutely still keep
it away from sand or dust it can now
survive a splash of water or falling
into a puddle and be totally fine so
that's dope also underrated the stereo
speakers are much better and fuller and
even if you block that small bottom
speaker grille with your finger the
earpiece speaker is also plenty loud too
so no worries that was well done i only
really have two minor complaints with
the build of this phone one it gets very
fingerprinty that's i guess a little bit
unavoidable or you could just skin it
but two uh the volume rocker is like way
up top on the side of the phone even
with big hands just the way you normally
hold a phone it's pretty unreachable so
it becomes a sort of a two-handed
operation to go up there and change the
volume i definitely wish they'd just put
it on the other side of the phone but
instead there's this cut out which i
believe is for the 5g antennas so i
guess i just wish they swapped those but
i guess aside from the hinge the most
important part on a phone like this
would be
the screen
and so there's really only one ambition
of a phone like this which is to unfold
into
a normal
phone experience and so this what you
get here
is a pretty big display unfolded it's
almost s21 ultra sized so it's a 6.7
inch 22x9 1080p bright oled display with
a hole punch cut out and it's 120 hertz
finally so this was my biggest ask from
the last version it just doesn't seem
right anymore to charge flagship money
for a phone with a 60hz display apple i
guess can somehow still pull it off
because people still buy iphones all the
time but this feels way better way more
smooth love the high refresh rate
experience now but a couple things about
this screen so first of all
the top of this the screen protector
it's a 30 harder cover glass on the
screen great feature but this top layer
of the screen protector is like cut out
around the selfie camera and it's pretty
annoying like it kind of looks like one
of those cheap pre-installed screen
protectors and it really makes me want
to remove it but samsung would really
like you to not remove it so that's
gotten pretty annoying although i'll
probably eventually get annoyed and take
it off but it's there but two uh the
crease the crease is definitely still
here in fact it hasn't changed all that
much from the last flip it's right
through the middle of the phone where
your finger
runs over it all the time when you're
scrolling through normal things like
social media or emails or whatever
you're doing so it's visually there but
it's also physically there since you
feel it so much i feel like it's both
annoying but also like no big deal at
the same time maybe i'm a little i'm a
person who's used a folding phone before
so i'm a little more used to the crease
than a normal person but it's true if
you just look at the content on the
screen you can definitely ignore it the
keyboard is below it doesn't touch it so
all that's fine but on the other hand
it's definitely still noticeable even if
you're just a little bit off axis it
catches your eye sometimes you know if
you're reading text it'll kind of droop
it in the middle a little bit so i'll
like scroll a bit extra to get the text
away from the middle it's weird i hope
they keep working on this because if
they could get it to feel even more flat
like a normal glass screen someday that
would be way better
but yeah i think that should be the next
big improvement minimizing this crease
and also trimming down the edges around
the display because it's still a bit off
on a thousand dollar phone to have to do
that gesture from the side but have your
finger hit a piece of plastic but flip
three
is all about that outside cover screen
so uh flip two as you can tell by my
shirt shop.adamkbhd.com
uh had a very very very small outside
cover screen it basically would just
show you the time and if you had a
notification right
then
moto razr came out
and while most of the rest of this phone
was pretty terrible it did have a
massive outside screen that turned out
to be very useful so now samsung's given
us a larger cover screen on the flip 3.
not as big as the razers but it's four
times the area as the last one and it
genuinely changes the way you use the
phone so actually do some quick stuff on
the outside screen now without opening
the flip so by default it's just time
date and battery plus a dot over on the
side if you have any notifications but
then you can change the visual on the
screen if you want to a bunch of
different things in the settings there's
a whole page you can change different
animations and different backgrounds and
clock styles you can even match it to
the watch face if you have a samsung
galaxy watch so that's pretty smart
but from there you can do a bunch of
stuff so you can swipe over to your
different widgets in whatever order you
want music weather a timer if you want
one some people might want their
calendar here it's not unlimited widgets
there's actually just a list of six you
can choose from that samsung's put in
here and you can choose to order but
even just these six are pretty useful so
if i'm playing a podcast or music which
i do all the time the music icon shows
up and then i can tap that to skip right
to the music controls widget and then
play or pause or fast forward or
whatever from here
also fun fact when the phone is closed
like this the volume buttons on the
outside reverse function so this up
direction increases volume and down
decreases but then it flips back when
you open up the phone again very smart
you know it would have been smarter
though google assistant on the outside
screen just like firing it up
asking it a question
uh that's not a thing available here
it does use bixby voice to answer text
messages which is
whatever it's fine but then also even
taking pictures on the outside screen is
way better you could do it before but it
was a tiny screen you didn't want to
this one
actually would so it's a decent sized
viewfinder and it's the primary camera
so they're kind of nice and you can
swipe up or down to change lenses and
swipe left or right to switch from photo
or video mode one thing to note though
is selfies from the main camera with the
cover screen will be a one by one square
aspect ratio and there's no way to
change that just a heads up
aside from that though you do get decent
selfie image quality from the primary
cameras which aren't quite flagship
level but they're pretty good same as
last year the primary and the ultra wide
and that kind of checks out across the
rest of the features of this phone like
i love that the cameras are basically
flush with this phone but aside from
that on a thousand dollar phone they're
fine nothing special the battery life
again you know this is a 3 300 milliamp
hour battery split between the top and
the bottom and it's powering a huge 120
hertz display so
it did better than expected but when it
taps out after four hours of screen on
time that's just
fine nothing special call quality again
fine
heat dispersion
only really warms up when wireless
charging on the rare wireless charger
that actually fits a phone this size
but again it's fine and on a phone like
this it might sound like i'm like
disappointed i'm saying oh it's fine
it's fine but really that's
kind of an accomplishment on a phone
that screen folds in half like that's
kind of amazing we are looking to
eventually get down to the point where
there's no major compromises or major
shortcomings and it delivers on the one
promise of being able to fold your phone
down into something that's theoretically
a bit more pocketable for people with
smaller pockets or for ladies with
purses and things like that
and it does it so it's not super flashy
or head turning it's not even as
ambitious as the fold three which is
trying to give you a normal smartphone
and a tablet in your pocket which is a
lot but the fact that it gives you a
normal smartphone experience
and folds in half
is very close to what i said at the
beginning and what i've been saying
since the beginning of this whole
foldables thing which will get them to
catch on this is a folding phone i can
actually start recommending to people
and the fact that we got this far
is crucial for them to move forward
but speaking of crucial
shout out to crucial for sponsoring this
video it's perfect okay so crucial a
brand of micron
has been really good and really
experienced with ssds now when i say ssd
might be picturing like one of these
guys that just goes into your computer
but crucial is one of the biggest memory
manufacturers in the world so they've
brought their expertise to making
external solid-state drives and these
guys are
super useful so a single external ssd
like this is going to give you
incredible performance reliable quality
and durability with zero moving parts
and they're compatible with not just
windows and mac os but chrome os the
xbox the ps5 android and the ipad pro
you know the one ios device that
actually has a usb c port it's a pretty
ideal universal solution to so many
things i've talked a lot about devices
in the past that have lower base storage
just to get away with having a lower
base price
and so you know cloud storage has been a
popular solution to this problem but
when you think about that economically
you want it to save money by going into
lesser storage but then you spend money
every single month to sort of rent that
space in the cloud which seems crazy
when you can just have
four terabytes in your pocket like this
so we use these in the studio here all
the time for transferring video files
and assets between computers but for you
i mean it's whatever you want the tiny
x6 offers up to four terabytes of
storage at 800 megabytes per second read
write or if you're like me and you just
need the speed you can get the crucial
x8 and that'll do a 1050 megabytes per
second for up to two terabytes of
storage so future proof yourself grab a
crucial ssd i'll have the link below if
you want to check out the x6 or the x8
and of course uh i have the x8 if you
care that's the one i carry with me all
the time in my backpack but that's
pretty much it thanks for watching
i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace